en el vídeo pasado vimos de un modo
quizás más formal al que estaban
acostumbrados que una función entre dos
conjuntos xy es sencillamente una
asociación entre los miembros del primer
conjunto y los miembros del segundo
conjunto así que sí por acá dibujo a
nuestro conjunto x que se llama nuestro
dominio y por acá dibujo al conjunto al
que estoy mandando las cosas que sería
nuestro co dominio en este caso el
conjunto y entonces una función
simplemente toma un elemento en x y lo
envía lo manda a un elemento en que lo
asocia con un elemento en y entonces
podríamos pensar en estos dos conjuntos
incluso en cosas muy abstractas por
ejemplo podríamos pensar en que x es una
canasta de manzanas y jason mccann
astaire plátanos y entonces la función
simplemente le asocia cada manzana de
esta canasta un plátano de esta otra
canasta y eso es una función entre la
canasta de manzanas y la canal de
plátanos y esto es interesante porque va
un poco en contra de la noción
preconcebida que tenemos de función en
la que las funciones generalmente se ven
algo así por ejemplo
podemos decir pues f x es igual a x al
cuadrado así que si ustedes me dan un
número x yo le hago alguna operación o
lo modificó de algún modo y les digo qué
número me da pero esto es una noción
muchísimo más general porque puede ir de
cualquier conjunto en cualquier conjunto
una función no está restringida al
conjunto de números reales son números
complejos o con números en general puede
ser cualquier conjunto ahora esto es
interesante porque podemos hablar de
vectores ahora podemos hablar de los
vectores nosotros sabemos que los
vectores son miembros de conjuntos de
hecho x pertenece a rn y así lo hemos
estado viendo hasta ahora y les recuerdo
brevemente les recuerdo brevemente que
definimos a rn hace ya muchísimo tiempo
al principio quizás de la lista de
álgebra lineal como el conjunto de n
hadas reales
reales y que eso ni nada pues es una
cosa de la forma es un especialista x 1
x 2 y así hasta x n n es simplemente una
etiqueta podría ser m o s o cualquier
cosa y lo que significa es que puede
tomar cualquier valor que sea un número
natural puede ser ese 1 entre 27 r 15
no importa lo único que pedimos es que
tanto x1 como x2 como x 3 así hasta x n
miembros de los números reales eso es lo
que definimos por rn y al decir al decir
que un vector x pertenece a rn lo único
que estoy diciendo es que es alguna
forma de escribir una lista de este
estilo hasta ahora hemos estado
considerando vectores columna que son de
la forma x es igual a algo de el estilo
x 1 x 2
y así hasta x n
donde donde cada x1 y x2 y así hasta x m
pertenecen a los números reales y ahora
es interesante porque podemos tener
funciones cuyo dominio sea rn y cuyo
condominio sea algún rm déjenme tratar
de hacer un dibujo por acá así que esto
vamos a decir que es r n ese es mi
dominio y vamos a tener la función que
va a algún
algún ere m n puede ser igual a m puede
ser distinto no me importa
simplemente son dos espacios vectoriales
rn ok entonces a un vector x aquí
en rn lo puedo asociar lo puedo asociar
con algún vector digamos d
d
rm y esto es interesante porque ahora lo
que acaba de hacer es construir una
función una función cuyo dominio es
rn y cuyo dominio es r m es una función
entre rn y rm déjenme una nota
aclaratoria acerca de la anotación
cuando escribo dos conjuntos y esta
flecha cuando escribo las cosas de esta
forma estoy simplemente diciendo que la
función va del conjunto rn al conjunto r
m lo digo porque en el vídeo anterior o
hace algunos vídeos introducen la
anotación en la que escribí a esta
función como decir f
efe toma el vector o al número equis y
lo envía a x al cuadrado y entonces
ponía esta especie de línea vertical
aquí lo único que significa cuando
escribo las cosas de este modo es que lo
que estoy dando es lo que se llama las
reglas de correspondencia les estoy
diciendo que hacerle exactamente esta
equis y adónde va a dar a dónde va a dar
esta x de este lado lo único que estoy
diciendo es es una función entre estos
dos conjuntos pero bueno regresando al
punto
bien entonces vimos que los vectores son
miembros de conjuntos y que las
funciones son simplemente asociaciones
entre elementos de conjuntos así que
tiene sentido que las funciones puedan
operar en vectores y de hecho ya había
hablado un poco de esto en alguno de los
vídeos anteriores decimos que si el dow
el co dominio
es un subconjunto
o
rm
con el mayor que uno estrictamente mayor
que uno entonces nuestra función es una
función vectorial o vector evaluada
esto es interesante porque ahora no
simplemente le está asociando a alguien
un valor real sino le está asociando
toda una lista de valores reales una
añada más bien una meada bien pues vamos
a hacer un ejemplo concreto vamos a
considerar la función
x 1 x 2 y x 3
le asocia
le asocia la pareja x 1 + 2 veces x 2 y
como segunda coordenada como segunda
entrada me habla de coordenadas pero
supongo que entienden le vamos a asociar
3 veces x 3 esa es nuestra función como
una función
esto va del conjunto de r3
porque esta es una terna ordenada es una
tres era la eterna ordenada
en el plano esto es una pareja ordenada
un par ordenado entonces esto está en r2
esto es una 12 hada normalmente decimos
terna y par en vez de troceada o 12 hada
pero bueno esto por supuesto también lo
podría escribir en notación vectorial y
en notación vectorial lo escribía así
efe del vector
la función aplicada al vector x 1 x 2 x
sería esto es un vector en r3 y sería el
vector en r2
cuya primera entrada es x1 más dos veces
x2 y cuya segunda entrada es 3 veces x 3
y bien vamos a ver cómo se ve esto qué
pasa si le aplicó la función le aplicó f
por ejemplo el vector 1 1 1
a este vector esto es tan sencillo
cuanto me da la función pues es uno más
dos por uno así que uno más dos por uno
es tres y luego tres por equis 3 3 por 1
estrés así que me da el vector 3 3
y qué hay de por ejemplo
por ejemplo el vector 24 12 41
en este caso la función me da el valor 2
más 2 por 4 2 más 2 por 4 es 2 + 8 que
es 10
y 3 veces x 3 sería 3 por 1 estrés así
que esto me da el vector en r 2 10 3 muy
bien y como se ve eso como podemos
visualizar esto en el espacio y en el
plano bien déjenme tratar de hacer un
dibujo de r 3 es un poco complicado y
quizás me va a quedar muy feo pero
el punto es usar nuestra imaginación y
tratar de ver cómo se ven los vectores
entonces el primer vector es el 1 1 1
si esta es mi dirección x 1 y esta es mi
dirección x2 y esta es mi dirección x 3
entonces
entonces el vector 111 sería uno para k
1 para acá y 1 para acá así que estaría
digamos que ese punto está flotando en
el espacio y entonces el vector en
posición estándar se vería algo así ok
ahora el segundo vector es el 24 1 así
que 2 en esta dirección
luego 1 2
4 así que estaría en este punto y luego
subo 1
como que me salgo de ese plano y acabo
por ahí entonces más o menos sería un
vector que se vería así les digo no soy
muy bueno dibujando pero estos dos
vectores no están en este plano están
como asaltados bien ahora como se ve r2
pues r2 sencillamente es algo así vamos
a poner estos son mis ejes
y esos son mis ejes
y entonces este vector el 111 se
transforma en el vector 33 digamos 123 y
a 23
así que ese vector se transforma en un
vector más o menos así
este vector de aquí
se transforma en este vector de acá o se
aplica podemos decir que se aplica en
este vector o que el vector asociado a
este vector es el vector de aquí bien y
qué pasa con el otro vector
pues el otro vector se va al 10 3 así
que 3 4 5 6 7 8
desde alto
así que el otro vector el vector naranja
de acá se transforma en este vector de
acá
este vector se convierte o se asocia con
este otro vector bajo la función f
viene aquí introduje una palabra
interesante dije muchas veces que este
vector se transformaba en este otro
vector y de hecho de hecho decimos que
una transformación
formación
y esto es palabra clave
una transformación es sencillamente es
un
función
una función que ópera
se opera en vectores
esa es una transformación es simplemente
por ejemplo efe es una transformación
solo que así como las funciones que
realmente se notan por la letra f de
función las transformaciones
generalmente se notan con la letra t
mayúscula y esto solo lo digo para que
si se encuentra en esa notación en algún
libro de texto no se vayan a confundir y
crean que es algo raro una
transformación es sencillamente una
función son conceptos idénticos aquí
podría cambiar todas estas veces por
test y sería lo mismo de hecho podría
decir que tengo una transformación t que
va de r3 en r2
donde te está definida por 'the x 1 x 2
x 3 es sencillamente x 1
x 1 + 2 veces x 2
y segunda entrada 3 veces x 3
y esto sería la misma transformación
estas dos funciones está efe estas son
exactamente la misma incluso podría
decir que por ejemplo t del vector
11 quien es pues es lo mismo que esto
así que es 33
el vector 33 en r2 y quizás el origen de
la palabra transformación viene de esto
de que este vector se está cambiando y
se está transformando en este otro
vector pero bueno lo importante este
vídeo lo que más me interesa que
entiendan es que los vectores como son
miembros de conjuntos pueden ser
cosas en las que operen funciones puedo
tener funciones de vectores y a esas
funciones se les dice transformaciones y
se anotan por la letra t espero que este
ejemplo les haya ilustrado un poco el
concepto en el próximo vídeo hablaré un
poco de lo que son las transformaciones
lineales que son realmente las
transformaciones las funciones que nos
interesan en el álgebra lineal así que
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo